i know a lot of people say they learn
from their losses but i get better
because of my successes mike told me
something the other day in the hotbox he
says you know he started thinking
differently about some of the stuff i
was saying to him i said you know mike
you think your success is what hurts you
but i guarantee if you look back those
first fights you were winning everything
brightened up in your life when you
started winning in life he ran you know
my grades got better he even learned
better i said you know i don't learn
from losses i learn from successes and
then i try to repeat those things the
bucket gets bigger the rim gets bigger
the field goal gets bigger right
everything gets bigger it's easier to
make the shot because i have the winds i
feel so bad for people particularly
around money that they never have the
victories back to back enough victories
to be like wow what else could i do the
only thing you're missing is momentum
you're a genius
you have great ideas that idea you have
in your head is amazing can't work can't
make a lot of money can impact the world
can serve the people around you you're a
genius you've got michael jordan level
talent at something you've got grant
cardone level talent at something you
you even know everybody telling you you
can't nobody's done it in your family
before nobody's done it for your
community before you can do it you've
got it the only thing the only only only
only thing that you're missing
is momentum
you're not doing enough you're not
getting enough results you're not
getting the little wins the little ones
like the bigger ones eat the more wins
and the bigger wins like the bigger wins
momentum
i have a youtube course
that i put out in once a month i'm in uh
a facebook group and we do a live chat
with the people who bought the course to
help them continue to grow and blow up
their channel
and two days ago i posted in the group
to say hey for our next call that's
coming up what do you want to learn
how can i help we've got this once a
month time together you and me
solo time like what can i help you with
what topics do you want to learn more
about
and you know what the number one
response was
the number one response that people
voted up was how to stay motivated when
you're not getting results
how to stay motivated when you're not
getting results it wasn't a tactical
thing it wasn't how do i fix my
thumbnails how do i fix my intros what
do i title my video do you like my color
scheme what topic should i create how
often do i post how long should your
video be none of that stuff is how do i
stay motivated when i'm not getting
instant early results
and so that's we're going to talk about
next week on the call when we get on
and i think back to when i first started
and there's lessons here for you not
just if you're interested in youtube but
whatever you're doing
when i first started
started speaking before i started doing
youtube and i remember i would go and do
a speaking gig and and my first one only
three people showed up and i would feel
such a high after the speaking gig like
man what what this matters this is
amazing i just helped some people and
then wake up the next day
and feel no energy no momentum it's like
man
i don't believe in myself anymore
who am i to go and do this all of a
sudden the question the doubt the
insecurities just take over again like
where was the oven from yesterday
and so what i did was
after every time i did a presentation i
asked for feedback and people would
email me their feedback and the best
feedback i put into a powerpoint file i
put into a powerpoint file and i've
watched this presentation every morning
that i made super simple put it to a
music soundtrack that i like and it
would just be
instant over and over and over again all
the feedback that i got to remind myself
that the work that i did matters because
yesterday it felt amazing because i was
out there speaking and helping people
but today it doesn't feel real anymore
it's crazy how that can happen overnight
and so i watched the powerpoint file
every morning to remind myself that the
work that i do matters that this is
happening that even if i've only touched
three people i touched three people it
helped them it was meaningful to them
and i have to keep going right it's a
small wins the momentum the only thing i
was missing was momentum the same thing
for you when i first started on youtube
the first video that i put up
was on walt disney and my mom commented
on it and my sister commented on it and
then one other random person i don't
know commented on it in the first year
so think about it the first year of me
having my youtube channel up my first
video
three comments on that video
and one was my mom and was my sister so
only really one comment from a stranger
someone i didn't know on my first video
after one year of it being live isn't
that crazy
and so what i would do is i'd look at my
comments every day and even though
they'd be the same comments because i
wasn't getting very many
even see my mom's comment or my sister's
comment or that one random dude's
comment knowing that hey
it touched that one random dude
i have to keep going
i gotta keep moving it
now i'm i'm spoiled you know every day i
still look at comments as part of my
daily routine as a reminder to myself
that this like this stuff the beach
views that kind of stuff that doesn't
motivate me it doesn't motivate me it's
fun being here i'm blessed i'm grateful
to have the kind of business that can
take me here and and travel around the
world new speaking gigs and all that
kind of stuff it's amazing but the thing
that gets me out that motivates me that
fires me up is knowing that people are
consuming my content and it makes a
difference that's a pelican right there
they've been trying to get that pelican
all day where's it where's he going
where are you going pelican
look look look hold on oh where'd he go
i'm losing him
where'd he go okay
these these pelicans are
hard to catch anyway knowing that the
work that i do matters and so still
today even though we get i don't know
how many comments every day it's still
the first thing i do is i look at the
comments every single morning look at
the comments know that the work that i
do matters and i would highly encourage
you to do the same whatever that
equivalent is if you're making youtube
videos or instagram content you know
look at the comments every day even if
they're the same comments as yesterday
it's okay like the work you do matters
it touches somebody that's the momentum
you need to just keep going and make one
more video one more piece of content
if you're making products or services
for customers
whenever you're talking to somebody if
you have an email exchange save the best
parts
save it and put into a word file or
powerpoint file and look at it every day
or post it on the wall print out the
email and put it on the wall
so you look at it every day like i
matter the work i do matters touches
people is meaningful i got to do more of
it because even if i'm not helping a
million people yet i'm helping one
person two people four people
that feeling that the work that you do
matters even to four people
it's enough to give you the energy to
keep going and doing something again
today that's what's missing from most
people that's what's missing for most of
you
momentum that's it
so email some customers
social media replies you had a great
meeting with somebody write down a quote
that stuck up to you because trying to
remember it the next day is really hard
trying to remember the next week the
next month is super hard what they said
so you just had a meeting with somebody
write it down write down the highlight
and how it made you feel and post that
on the wall
you need to surround yourself in a
physical environment built of momentum
with daily habits that build your
momentum
because if you did that
if you woke up every day
and we're reminded
of the impact that you're having at
least on a couple people's lives and you
genuinely felt like the work that you
did matters to people
even on a small scale
it'll give you the thing that you need
most
which is momentum and the feeling of
hope and belief that it's possible to
keep going to keep creating to keep
making
and that your mission is going to work
out
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
all commitments require investments in
time and money all commitments
you cannot make a commitment without
time and money being invested
time and money has to be invested you
have to invest time and money
if it's not on your schedule you're not
committed if you don't have money back
by that time on your calendar if it's
not costing you money or you don't have
money deposited right there you are not
committed
where you have your money is where your
personal spiritual emotional physical
commitments go wherever your money is is
who you are most committed to
wells fargo bank of america citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
wells fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising the market
because you guys are committed to the
lie
the big marketing scam of the universe
save your money
[Music]
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not bore
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
and one day you too will be able to stay
at a holiday inn
for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there
and eat all you want for as long as you
want by the way
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the
belt that you bought and put on your
credit card
that you can't write off
so this is what americans are doing
people all around the world spend 40
hours a week running around hustling
yeah they get a hundred dollars what do
they do now they run over here to the
bank drop off the hundred bucks then
they run back out and do another 40
weeks pick up a thousand dollars man i
had a great week didn't i bang and then
they run over here and drop it off to
the bank these are the good americans
[Music]
the bad americans go pick up a thousand
bucks go to the club and blow it
the good americans
run run around collecting a thousand
dollars five thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars hustlers hustlers man
hard workers they they get sophisticated
oh i'm going to put a little money in
the bank over here over here at wells
fargo i'm going to have a little over
here at citibank i'm going to spread
this
around
i want to be a slave to many
not a slave to a few
i'm going to give a little the bank of
america i'm going to give a little bit
of citibank i'm going to give a little
bit to the wells fargo i'm going to give
a little bit to fidelity and merrill
lynch i'm going to give a little bit to
my ira and my 401k i'm going to bust my
ass i'm going to spend 40 years killing
myself to make sure all these
institutions
have my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey mr cardone
[Music]
we got another dummy
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours
put together a little bank extremely
disciplined dumbass
and and he
saved hundred thousand dollars with us
and we'd like to know mr cardone
if you would like to borrow that money
his money
yeah i sure would because we know mr
cardone that you will put that money to
work
okay
this guy that gave it to us all he wants
to do is work
i'm like yeah send me that money bro
send me that money okay and they by the
way they're not done calling me they're
gonna call nine other people
they're going to take his 100 grand and
they're going to say they're going to
they're going to lend it out
900 000
of it and this is the banking system
and that is debt by the way
that u.s dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you
people say the dumbest things it could
be family it could be your wife your
husband it could be a a mom a dad a
uncle an aunt it could be your kids
coming from school people say what they
think and what they think will be what
they say and what they say and think
often enough long enough reinforced
enough i promise you will be what they
do okay so look at some of the dumb
things you say like this here's one dumb
thing people say
time heals all things
really
you get a splinter in your foot and you
don't pull the splinter out you don't
look at it confront it and say i got to
pull that little
booger out i got to pull that little
splinter out if you just leave it there
you might get used to it yeah you'll get
used to it 30 years goes by you still
got a splinter in your foot who knows
that splinter gets into your bloodstream
goes to your heart spikes your heart
kills you time does not heal all things
folks you know what heals all things
taking a look at it having the courage
to look at it hey what happened to me
how did i screw up here what what hurt
or what pain or what happened that i had
a loss i see people go through life with
all these losses unwilling to look at
them all crippled by the time they get
older not old but they looking old
because they believe that time heals
look time heals when you confront it
when you look at it when you pull the
splinter out and take responsibility for
it don't believe everything you believe
you know what i'm saying because some of
the ideas you got they just dumb
and dumb things will cause you to do
dumb things the reason the guys on wall
street and the gals on wall street make
so much money
okay it's not because they're they're
they're like capitalists and they're
terrible people it's because they're
surrounded by people that are making
money man they're accountable by their
stock price they're accountable to their
production they got people around them
that expect them to win and do well and
also they're going to dinner waking up
at breakfast working out in the gym with
other people that are winning big in
life okay so you need feedback from your
environment and your network fourth
thing you need is you got to have fifth
thing you need is you got to have a
network of people that are encouraging
you
to kill it you got to have the right net
you got to have a lebron in your game
man if you're playing in the nba and
lebron's like i'm gonna take you under
my wing bro
okay kobe's like hey man i wanna i'm
coming back to be with you man what
would you deny that okay michael jordan
i want to be with you man tiger woods i
want to golf with you come on guys what
are you doing you cannot do this alone
you cannot do this alone are you kidding
me man let's say you want to be a
surgeon and a top surgeon in the world
is like i want to take you under my wing
what are you going to do i'm too busy
this isn't a magic act these are basic
skills
and basic skills are duplicatable
and the reason most salespeople have
such trouble is because for years we
have been trying sales professionals and
the gurus have been teaching
uh manipulation tactics
dodge the question
don't answer control the customer
uh the the whole newer linguistics board
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro linguistics
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the llp stuff i'm
just telling you we've hired
hundreds and hundreds of sales people
i've been with tens of thousands of
sales people i have never seen one
person that got into this neuro bullet
it was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
i don't want drama dude i want
production
so
so when when he sits a certain way i
don't start thinking about man i'm
imagine being in a sales sales
presentation i'm like i got to be like
him and then now i got to be like her
and now i got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that
you
you man what a diss
i want to be me
the power resonates for me my truth my
authenticity and my transparency
okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it i never ask him to be
me i'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say
well i'm with you
everybody try that
no no i didn't say it like that i said
i'm with you see and i'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high i knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay see i i'm he he gets to be him
but the words will work because all i'm
doing is basically agreeing with the
customer this isn't a trick here
okay uh this course is uh i'm doing a
dinner tonight for 25 000 at my house
okay i think we got two slots left
the entire 25 000
goes to the grant cardone foundation any
of you want to put 25 grand in please
see one of my people come have dinner at
my house we'll spend a couple hours over
there the money's going to go to help
kids some of you in a room immediately
say
oh my god 25 grand that's a lot of money
man i know that
you don't think i know 25 000 a lot of
money i'm the one that decided what the
freaking entry would be i said what
would be too much 25 grand
25 grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like that damn that's
a lot of money okay and the people that
it's a lot of money that think small
that go small and don't want to help
won't come to my house and have dinner
and the people they're like dude i'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
grand get pictures with him at his new
home
with his family with with eight or ten
other people and the money's going to
charity and i get to write it off i get
to bang the irs who hates the irs
well this is this is a chance to give
them a
[Music]
good okay so you see what i'm doing i'm
handling all the objections right now i
understand 25 grand a lot of money man i
know what you got to do to earn 25 grand
you got to do crazy stuff to earn 25
grand and if you keep thinking that
earning 25 grand is always going to be a
problem for you hopefully for everybody
in a room one day you're going to be
able to earn 25 000 every hour
every business i have five companies now
we'll do a hundred million this year i
started every one of those companies
with no money zero money man just hustle
and grit and courage
i've called on people i didn't want to
be with i've done things i didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes to make your dreams a reality to
be closed and stay closed if you're not
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
man 400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you 400
do it
listen to me man you're 32 years old
you've been trying to save money for 20
years and you hadn't do it and do it now
i don't need anything special here i'm
not going to be empathetic quit being
stupid write to check
i don't know if the compliance guy likes
that or not
but i know this look if you believe in
what you're selling how many of you
believe in what you're selling
then close the deal
then close the deal okay learn to close
and you'll never be without work you'll
never be without money you'll have an
organization that is booming in
affluence
you'll have a pipeline full you'll have
appointments filled up
right i call it a a group called me
yesterday i'm actually trying to do a
deal with cnbc and the guy says i'm
interested i said good i'll be there
tomorrow call me back i'll be i'm flying
into new york tomorrow what am i trying
to do right now by the way i was
supposed to be here
i'll fly into new york tomorrow i can be
there tomorrow mr ackerman okay how does
that work
i can't do tomorrow i was going to be
here anyway and i'm trying to close the
deal let me close the deal i'll figure
out how to be in two places at one time
later
right you some of you in the room
they're like hey i could see you at four
o'clock on tuesday right and the
customer says to you i'll see you at
four o'clock
let me look at my calendar like like
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
[Music]
it's dishonest man
you want to see me tuesday four o'clock
i give you tuesday at four o'clock agree
today done
done i'll call you if something changes
if there's an earthquake between now and
next tuesday tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and i can't be there
you think everybody understands
commit first figure to rest out later
close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your calendar's got the
devil all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil
you don't need to die okay you go two or
three days without anything going on how
many of you start having doubts
you're in hell
oh my god this ain't gonna work for me
there's nobody coming in i'm not gonna
hit my target okay i know what i'll do
i'll lower my target
that's the devil doing that man that's a
criminal
never ever if you're taking notes never
lower a target
never lower a target never lower a
target your mom and dad would tell you
to lower a target a manager might tell
you to lower target be reasonable
be reasonable with yourself
just bring it down a little bit no man
criminal products are created like that
a guy sees the girl that he wants that's
the girl she says no he goes to another
girl
right he gave up on his dream
if you're going to give up in your own
dream how are you going to build an
organization for me like i was always
scared of money you know and and i was
terrified of it so so like if you look
at still today like i look at the bill
of everything
it's a bill of everything
if something caused something i want to
know how much it was
and so like
how much is it like i'm going to ask
that question
whether whether it matters or not i'm it
doesn't matter where i get in my life i
i don't think i'm ever going to be free
of how much was that how much is the
dinner how much how much was dinner how
much was the tip how much was the code
how much was the jacket what did you
know me me and elena like elena's like
hey it's going to be fine man like look
what look look
look at what you've done we cannot spend
this and i'm like how much was it
i want to know how much it was because
when i grew up do you had to know what
things cost and so the point your
question about money is it's a
terrifying thing because
it's the one thing in life
that
you know the nfl is not going to give me
the ball
and and i'm never going to get a chance
to golf i can't win in those
environments but with money
everybody gets money it's the one place
where everybody gets it and now what do
i do
and i can lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power
you know very few of us ever ever get
any kind of influence or power right
once you get it you're like hey what do
i do with this
you know am i going to do it am i going
to do the right things with it and so i
think people withhold themselves because
they don't we're not educated about
money we don't know where it comes from
we have a lot of misinformation about it
our parents terrified us
you know money doesn't grow in trees
uh save your money it'll save you all
these these these things our parents
told us because they were enamored
or are encumbered
with the same kind of liabilities around
money right i don't know how to get it
i don't know how to keep it
and the
the third the worst part that we're all
at is i don't know how to invest it yeah
so what i'll do is i'll some people get
good at getting it
very few actually fewer people at
keeping it
but probably more than getting it
there's probably a big group in america
that have learned how to keep money
because they're afraid to lose it they
don't want to invest it they don't want
to use it they don't want to you know um
you know kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like i had an uncle he
buried everything he ever made they were
in the backyard wow
the other uncle was was uh he was he was
a guy that bought he he worked hard very
very frugal
italian descent
and he would uh buy real estate but it
was always buy low and sell high he
actually never sold anything but that
was the concept buy low buy the cheapest
lowest
get everything on a deal if there's food
stamps to be gotten you go get those
food stamps if there's a if there's a
government deal get it if it's section 8
and the government will pay you pay it
so both these guys different kind of
mentalities were extremely frugal
my other uncle
was uh worked in a refinery he basically
saved all his money paid everything off
got out of debt that was their lifestyle
my dad died when i was 10. so he paid
all his debt off had everything paid and
so that's all i had right everybody
around me was like get money
keep it keep it don't use it you know
but but you should invest but nobody
ever learns that third one
and and so i think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified
of this
this apparent
apparency of it's scarce right
and it's not
and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it if you're
reading a book
okay you listening to music
going to an event
uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in an event
it's it's the 700th time you did that
presentation you got to show up new
again
johnny comes to work with his camera and
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new ladies and
gentlemen you're new
every day you're new or
guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterdays
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some [ __ ] but it's got
to be fresh i need some fresh [ __ ]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[ __ ] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either i'm making 2.4 million
dollars a year
if i could figure out how to get another
200 that's called value add v8 value ad
if i could figure out how to raise the
rents 200 bucks
531
units see that's why the number of units
is so apart
531
106 000
times what
is what one point
see that creates another 1 million
274 000 of income a year
i'm already making 2.4 million dollars a
year
bam
that traffic jam
okay i got more cash flow
i just got i don't have to go work i
don't have to beat stuff up
i don't have to go uber you guys are
i'm going to go uber so what what you go
uber to
you end up with seven dollars
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
freedom
i don't want money this money i've had
this money here the whole time okay
it ain't gonna do anything
how many got money in the bank right now
it's useless
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money
and then they spend it
and you're just doing this thing
comes in it goes out
you have to have multiple exits on the
way out
how do i get out of this deal
i know people that have bought real
estate that they're like at cash flows
but they're like i cannot i can never
get rid of this piece of property it's
always going to be a problem for me hang
me around my neck
[Music]
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it i promise you you
will not lose money in this space
warren buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when i read that i'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do i invest in
oh invest in something that doesn't lose
money don't speculate don't buy stocks
like i don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper
when you go buy twenty dollars with a
google stock what do you get
you get a piece of paper bag
it's all made up
you can't steal it anyway
okay i want something i can see would
you agree
okay i would rather have that that money
i'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars i'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and i'm gonna buy a flip
chart
this flip chart is more value
than that hundred dollars
if i use it
everybody agree okay so i want you to
write this down quit saving money
[Music]
the banks have brainwashed you
save your money save your money save
your money save your money the the wall
street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
ill-liquid and you do not want to save
money you will never
ever experience great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life i have had
to give up something i wanted
i'm not talking about getting rid of the
bad stuff you got to get rid of
something that you actually worked for
to get
it might have been the house
it might have been oh my kids are in the
best schools now it's going to be
something painful for you to get to the
next place you have to give up something
that you worked for really really hard
so i sold my house one day i had this
cognition hey to get what you want you
have to give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life i had to leave lake charles
louisiana went went to houston had to
leave houston once i got comfortable
with my community and my friends had to
leave san diego had to go to l.a l.a is
a pit
compared to la jolla nobody goes from la
jolla california up to los angeles
nobody does that you'll leave kansas
city to go to los angeles
because you want to be an actor i met
elena within five minutes of arriving in
l.a
i sold my house i sold my house i didn't
leave it vacant
as a backup plan i left this house okay
like i couldn't buy this house today if
i wanted to it was so like it was a
precious little treasure
i had to give that up by the way i had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant i couldn't walk into i could
always get a seat i could always get the
best seed i had it right in my hand this
is what i'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life that you're gonna
consult that everybody's gonna consult
every one of you gonna hey what do you
think should i
you better have that person on your side
in my case i was by myself
so my consultant was like you gonna do
this dog i called my buddy dale dale you
think i should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what do you have to risk
sold the house went to los angeles lived
in a hotel i went from a house on the
ocean to living in a hotel the hotel
room was probably like i don't know
maybe the size of the stage
so please please do whatever you got to
do this weekend to figure out whatever
you got to do to get rid of whatever is
holding you back most of which is
something you worked hard to get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it i'm 63 years old you know i'll be 64
in march and
you know i feel like i'm like 14 years
old man i'm like let's roll like let's
let's go i'm ready to run through walls
and
you know fly and learn new stuff i'm
studying uh kryptos right now in the
metaverse and like what happens and when
do i make a play and do i make a play
and what is all this
so you one number one you have to stay
curious
[Music]
number one curious you have to be
curious when clubhouse came around
clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple years ago most of the people in
my office including jared was like man
ain't nothing there's nothing there
you know i'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what i
discovered because i was curious about
clubhouse is not because i was curious
about social media i was curious about
people
to me i get energy from people
and so uh
i've been in rooms where
uh alan have y'all met alan yet
so alan allen saw me go in the room one
night and he texted me he's like what
the hell are you doing in this room man
and i said what's up he's like get out
of this room
and i said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
[Music]
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
i said bro where how am i going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks
just because it has nothing to do with
you doesn't mean your market's not there
and for me to be able to market to a
market
means i need to understand how that
market thinks
so one of the great benefits of me being
curious particularly about two-way
communication on social media the
feedback
i'm not looking for likes and comments
i'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential an idea like all my ideas come
from i don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
i don't i don't create anything i just
grab something that's already there
and i grab it out of something i hear
so the supreme court today announced
they kicked out the mandate uh for the
vaccine i'm like hey man
okay go you like it or don't like it
y'all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh i don't want to
be political
say that's stupid man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing
and most of it's just a scam
and everybody knows it like i'm throwing
in they ain't throwing in for their side
they're throwing in to keep the other
side that they're worried about
the point of the story is there's energy
there
there's tremendous amounts of energy
that you want to you want to tap into if
you could walk the line and play both of
them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though so when
that came out today i'm like good job
man like i got to take a stand on that
now will i lose some people 100 percent
i don't care who i lose there's 8
billion people on this planet
i'm worried about who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it
that's the only way to protect your
brand you know i'm always keeping it
real with you what has happened to our
country that we make our idols and our
icons and our heroes rappers and
entertainers and ball players and then
we show discuss
for a businessman that can bank 50
million a year or 20 million a year what
is wrong look when a guy can go out and
make passive investments great decisions
execute show tremendous discipline okay
and disconcert between good investments
and bad investments and then make 20
million or 30 million bucks pay three or
four million dollars in taxes three or
four million dollars to his charities
his churches his community helps out
with groups of people
and and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year
making great investments great decisions
showing leadership in the marketplace
look that marketplace out there that
economy is the most savage
most
difficult
playing field in the world to negotiate
yet
who do we admire in our culture
rock stars look these guys got great
skills kid gets out of school makes 12
million a first year and and we make
posters of them and sweatshirts
and you put their kids in their jerseys
what about the business people that make
our economy work to pay the taxes that
make the schools work the churches work
that make the the fire department the
police department because they pay taxes
because they're out there making great
investments look admire business people
that are able to bank year after year
admire these people study them learn
from them don't be disgusted with them
and turn off anybody anybody that would
suggest to you that making money in this
country is wrong look don't envy
business people admire them emulate them
learn from them particularly these guys
are doing it year after year after year
not just on income but on wealth
development because that's where you
need to be that's where you need to be
thinking that's the economy you want to
create for yourself your family your
household and your future man did you
hear that the
the person that won the lottery i got
two points to make here the person that
won the lottery is 84 years old her name
is gloria mc mckenzie
here in florida she'll pay no state
taxes on that winning i keep telling you
guys move to a tax-free state so that
your income's not taxed and hey if you
win the freaking lottery 380
million freaking dollars
you wouldn't be taxed at 10 or 13
what are you thinking man the second
point here is this
this woman would not have won this
lottery ticket had it not been for the
guy in front of her being so gracious to
look at 84 and say hey lady you want to
go in front of me i guess he was worried
that she'd die before she could buy the
ticket okay folks in my book called if
you're not first you're last
i basically explain
look man if you're first in line you
don't give it up to an 84 year old i
know that might sound you know without
compassion and and uncaring and not
sensitive
hey when you're buying a lottery ticket
get in get out as quick as possible if
you're not first your last in this case
i hope 84 gives this guy a little
squeeze of the cheese please
let's find out how gracious 84 is with
her 380 to the guy that got out of line
to get her in the line
to buy the ticket that won the money
where she don't pay any state taxes in
florida
showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand doesn't mean you came to
work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up my body went in
the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test you freaking get a
perfect grade means you keep showing up
to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success so you got
to keep showing up showing up means
you're looking for deeper levels to show
up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what what's it why don't
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference man
showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up my wealth
ultimately is not the money i have it's
the knowledge i have
and the belief i have in myself the same
thing for you
but i want to take you on this trip
because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it
you know in the physical universe you
can explain to me what a bougainvillea
is you can explain to me what a beach is
you can explain to me what
uh the gym looks like on the second
floor in cabo san lucas at this
beautiful hotel we're at but
until i visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales
to the sunshine to the mountains until i
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind i was i was doing a
call today with percy miller uh master p
and he's like first thing you got to do
is see it in your mind he grew up in
extreme poverty in the projects and he
says grant first thing i had to do was i
had to see it
in my mind that i could get out second
thing i had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical universe
uh that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip
you can see the possibility of elon
going to mars you know and and all of a
sudden all those things expand
possibilities so number one you got to
see it in your mind too you got to see
it in the physical universe and this
also includes other people examples of
other people that are doing great things
i'm not just talking about physical
manifestation i'm not talking about
stuff
i'm not talking about watches and
bracelets and rings and houses and cars
i'm talking about how can you actually
manifest something in the real world
that you have in your mind how do you
turn an idea
into reality
and uh these things that i'm sharing
with you will make i'll make it a
possibility
when you dig deep on them though it's
like okay well how do i get closer to
people that are doing those things
because the third thing is you got to
get closer to the thing you want if you
want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem on planet earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company an airport and
actually fuel them clean them wash them
maybe you got to be a flight attendant
on them put your feet next to them maybe
you have to become a pilot you're going
to have to pay the price though there's
no free lunch here for anybody including
my children there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at it on the internet
the moment you can get in it it'll be
become even more real to you the fourth
thing is you got to put your feet in
this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there i
can you can visualize a horse you can
see the horse
you you got to touch the horse and the
fourth thing i'm sorry you got to touch
the horse and the fourth thing is you
guys got to collaborate with other
people man you got to get in the room
with other people whether you're serving
water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um offer to serve them to sit down okay
there's a story in my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse
on the internet in a magazine a picture
of it third get closer to it put your
feet on it on the plane on the horse on
the beach in the hotel if i got to go
work there to do it and the fourth thing
is
you got to network with people that have
stuff
okay
again uh i spent some time this week
with uh dame dash she's like look you
got to get close to the action you got
to get with the people that are making
the moves you cannot make the moves from
your own neighborhood
uh percy miller told me you cannot make
the moves from the projects you got to
move from the projects not make the
moves in the project quit working street
corners
quit selling just a product and start
hanging out with people that have scaled
their think
their ideas
into a reality you have to prepare for
inflation hitting you
and
look i just want to give you a heads up
on this thing it's happening right now i
believe we're already in a recession not
to be a doomsday guy because i think
that there's ways for you to take
advantage of this but i just passed one
two three four five six shops and
nobody's in them
so the american consumer has like 18
trillion dollars between cash accounts
and money markets you can't get negative
right now when you see the bad news this
is an opportunity for you and your
family to actually expand
not contract
so you're going to see bad news in the
headlines everywhere once the the
politicians start allowing
the mass media to actually distribute
the bad news and we're not talking about
you crane and cobid we're not talking
about abortion uh
rulings because all that is just
distraction for the bigger problem which
is the economy
the economy is problematic okay you got
the fed pushing interest rates
uh half a point yesterday
there was a rebound in the stock market
this morning i wake up
the stock market rolls over by a
thousand points okay there's going to be
blood in the market so i'm going to do a
training on this i'm going to give you a
few tips right now but i'm going to
click i'm going to give you a link to a
training for those of you who actually
want to do something about this and not
just hear the bad news
and be woken up first thing is you got
to wake up you got to wake up to what's
happening you got to know that hey
what do i do now what do i do if this
happens one do not buy into the bad news
okay two you got to expand into the
opportunity and it's very very difficult
to do
you've heard of wealthy people doing
this before how they take advantage of
situations okay i'm gonna show you how
to do that whether you have cash or no
you don't have cash whether you have
credit or don't have credit
because during times of contraction what
happens is
for instance there's 32 million small
businesses in america
many of you are going out trying to
start a new business where what you
ought to do is just kind of slide
sideways and go buy one the neighbor
next door to you i mean from laundry
mats to plumbers to internet businesses
to coaching businesses you name it
chiropractors dentists like in every
sector that you're involved in right now
in your business or your interest or
your passion i'll promise you
there are
thousands
thousands not one or two but thousands
of small businesses like yours
that are similar to your passion that
would feed your passion that already
have branding already have marketing
built in already have a name already
have a location already have revenue
already have credit lines that you can
literally just slide into
okay but you're not going to do that
you're not going to do that if all
you're doing is buying into bad news
so number one you can't buy into the bad
news because
remember all bad news sooner or later
is beat out by the need to survive and
the economy to go on the economy will
always go on
okay not just here in america but around
the world always always always we always
get on the other side of bad news so the
first thing you do is you got to keep
your head out of the garbage dump
you got to stay positive and trust me
when it goes negative
it is not easy to stay positive
people always like oh yeah i can stay
positive on my own probably not because
you're not going to be on your own
you're you'll be surrounded by bad news
everywhere so number two you got to
think about how do you expand despite
the fact that you don't have money and
you don't have credit or you do have
money and you do have credit but you
don't want to use either one because
you're terrified and you will be the
third thing you have to figure out to do
okay is exactly what sectors will
survive
long term
what sectors are going to win through
contractions because what happens in a
contraction
what happens is weak businesses get
squeezed out weak names get squeezed out
okay a weak operators get squeezed out
and the strong come in and take over
that either the technology takes over
and disrupts a space or a person
typically a person or an operator comes
in and then scales that business
now what i'm going to look to do here in
the next couple years is actually
accelerate my expansion
accelerate my expansion because i know
how to operate i know the four things
you have to do in a business to make a
business successful there's only four
things you must do to keep a business
one profitable two expanding and three
flourishing
there's four things and only four things
okay i don't have time right now because
i'm with my family uh but but when you
click the link below what i'll do is
i'll give you a free training on those
four things that you have to do look you
will get through this i promise you're
gonna get through this the question is
you gonna get through it and you're
gonna do great you're gonna flourish and
prosper you're gonna be like these
businesses waiting waiting
for traffic last thing i'm gonna tell
you is this
okay
don't
get
stuck in mechanics
when i'm writing my goals down i do not
know how i'm going to do it
so i merely sit down like i remember for
years i would write down i own a
helicopter i don't even know where this
concept came from i own a helicopter i
own a helicopter i own a helicopter
every once in a while it would show up
it would show up on a wednesday and not
show up for uh when i'm writing my goals
down right so i'm waking up in the
morning i wake up in the morning i write
my goals down and one day i write i own
a helicopter
i think back then it was a i learned how
to fly a helicopter
okay it was stupid it was completely
ridiculous i'm like where did that come
from
it just kind of floated into my mind i
wrote it down okay i own a jet
i'm like man i'm just being stupid right
now i own a jet and two helicopters
i don't know how that happened i didn't
i didn't know anything about jets
uh i would not achieve any of this by
the way until i was
53 years old 54 years old
the first private jet i was ever on was
the one
we bought
i didn't know anything about it i didn't
know how they fly i didn't know how they
work i didn't know what the cost of a
hangar was i know nothing don't get lost
in the mechanics i didn't know the fuel
cost i didn't know what it cost to buy
one do you finance them do you pay cash
do you get a tax rate i knew nothing
when i started writing this down the
helicopter would come after the jet okay
i bought a helicopter i didn't know why
so the point of that story is when
you're writing your goals down literally
sit down with a blank sheet of paper
first thing you wake up in the morning
and you just start zip zip zip zip you
right through them like this morning i
wrote down 40 billion in real estate
okay public i write down one word i'm
going public
see i know now that this this is in
present tense and our past tense i write
it in present or past tense i'm going
public okay i wrote down recently uh
a congressional hearing
people like what's a congressional
hearing dude i'm so big now they called
me into congress
they're gonna have a congressional
hearing they're gonna drill me
okay oh yeah then i wrote this down uh a
political office
now i don't know why
i don't know why i'm writing that down i
don't know how to achieve that i don't
know what it would mean i don't know
what it looks like i don't get stuck in
the mechanics don't worry about it
commit first man just keep committing it
keep fueling and keep writing it down if
you want to see the one on one i did
recently with grant check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created investing
elon musk is completely invested
he has no cash and no houses